morial vous avez eu des eaux vous avez
eu débat on va faire une interview à
peine d'arts pluriels ce que vous
préférez en vous ou pas de compassion
naturelle d'un agent est tout le temps
est toujours quoique si vous ne
supportez pas en vous quand on oblige à
plus à voir compassion pour me protéger
parce que ça va trop loin
je laisse des plumes quoi votre plus
gros coup de fric à part l'a pas non
plus beaucoup de fric alors celui là
j'aime bien elle aime bien parce que
c'était il ya en 81
11 est une marque enfin c'est une marque
et vip qui la charcuterie cérons comme
ça et pluri s'appelle bâtons mis
d'accord et oui et m'a sollicité et
c'était un contrat en 91 moi ça faisait
pas longtemps que je commençais à est
proposée sur une campagne de trois ans 9
millions de francs et j'ai dit j'ai
besoin de réfléchir et ça m'a pris une
nuit j'ai vu tout ce que je pouvais je
pense à ma famille à mes soeurs fin bref
à tout ça c'est surtout que j'ai dit je
ne vais pas le faire parce qu'il n'ya
aucune somme d'argent qui justifiera
tout pendant 5 ans 10 ans 15 ans et 10
jan une personne 10 personnes qui dans
la rue me lisent rabat 11 d'âge et trop
coûteux y'a pas l'argent nous forger
non votre plus grosse paire c'est ça
dont vainqueur 6 1 voilà d'accord le mot
que vous dites le plus facilement
merci le mot vous dites le moi
facilement shrek sous une très jolie pas
ça c'est sûr ça ne peut que me fait le
plus rire dans la vie des gens qui
disent oui si vous faites moi rire
ce qui me fait moins rire c'est qu'on ne
trouve pas une réponse à une question il
répond c'est pas bien et puis d'autres
aujourd'hui il y en a eu beaucoup
certainement mais bien sûr mais je pense
à un qui allait et voilà le dernier
mardi c'était lors de la dernière régis
un mail le matin depuis a pas mal qui
m'a dit qu'il allait bien qu'il avait
arrêté
excédé m'ont tous actes s'en était sorti
et qui les deux me dire qu'il me mais en
vrai qu'il avait il m'a écrit comme j'ai
2 bras gilles muriel dans ma vie ce
thème là je l'attendais depuis 15 ans
est-ce que bagarre il va pas ce que
c'est comme ça et là la compassion quand
même temps mais j'ai été obligé de la
chaire but joe serock quand vous
utilisez de lâcher ce que je dis c'est
carré oui je serai pas possible c'était
et ça c'est un moment et je dis bien
évidemment je suis tu peux passer ce
soir il est arrivé à la fin du spectacle
n'est monté sur cette annonce si c'était
à refaire
j'ai eu une pierre que j'aime tullamore
revue un croyez si tu le regardes
et pierre bien merci pour tes fleurs à
ses très gentil le plus mauvais moment
de votre vie maintenant
ouais ce qui vous détend le plus dans la
vie ce qui vous énerve le plus mais
énervement votre plus belle histoire
d'amour
le public de barbarie mais bon ça fait
bon gré et comme la pêche et je pensais
des personnes qui ont traversé ma vie
ouais c'est pas grave entendre me
comprenez bien que ça c'est la bonne
voilà c'est comme ça d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs c'est parce qu'on y met tous
ces stands à moins que la vie privée
j'en prenais beaucoup la plus minable
histoire d'amour et pas de minables de
choses minables dans ma vie thierry je
vous remercie
mesdames messieurs l'endroit où vous
rêveriez d'être en ce moment si vous
étiez pas ici dans mon pays mais en
train de regarder cette émission
l'endroit vous détesteriez transforme
ils veulent alors des comores nous
empêche de dormir
l'amour c'est compliqué a ouais c'est
sûr mais c'est dans le ventre mais c'est
ce que vous avez vous dû oser la boule
l'a1
comme souvent vides à bhl c'est comme
c'est le seigneur quel est votre
meilleur souvenir de cuite gtx josiane
balasko et ça se voyait qu'il n'était
pas bien j'avais moins duquel et moi
toujours prévenant qu'il y ait joseph
chanter je ne sais pas bien
c'est dans ce crunch il vaut mieux y a
pas fini de le dire mais je m'étais
payer un ensemble un truc loire dans les
marques japonaises intrus a été sa
chemise balle que stark bois c est l
aigle à gué bon mec c'était voilà
c'était alors voilà on va être pas le
mal tout à l'heure à mon agent j'ai posé
la question j'ai dit quel est votre pire
souvenir de cuite mais je me souviens
pas j'étais beau ce que vous avez fait
dont vous êtes la plus fière c'est pas à
montrer fier c'est pas très grave entre
éclats mais je pense que si c'était
normal je pourrais être fiers par
exemple de savoir que je ne suis pas
pour rien dans la construction d'un
hôpital à kaboul voilà mais je suis
patient je suis contente
bon c'est vrai que vous n'avez pas vous
n'avez pas d'enfants mais vous occuper
quand même des enfants arrivant au
niveau à pour vous c'est pas que je vous
dis non numéro privé
oui oui qu'ils aient un pareil c'est un
mec qui ne manque jamais de boue y avait
trois fois qu'ils téléphonent faut pas
l'appeler sur mon portable monsieur
rappelé rappelle dans un petit moment il
est pas encore là monsieur merci non il
est pas encore là d'accord c'est
l'époque budget cet hôpital c'est
magnifique quoi ce que voilà on a dit
qu'on le ferait on l'a fait trois ans et
demi les 152 salariés au moment où on se
parle peut-être qu'ils sont couchés mais
105 ans voilà les premiers enfants ont
été opérées on appellerait là-bas à
lesterps on opèrerait fonceuse oxygène
et c'est non mais c'est vrai que c'est
pas fier mais quand je fais un vrai les
yeux je ne regretterai jamais la voir
comme ça à savoir qu'il ya peut-être un
moment à l'enfant qui est sauvé et que
j'allais dire que j'y suis pour quelque
chose je veux pas le dire tellement
franck est sauvé voilà peut être avec
deux loges pour le sort de la jeune
professeur deloche eric cheysson et
sourçage apporter ce clip syrie reste
alain deloche c'est des mecs ça nous
vont à la caméra sur nous faire voilà un
relais de loches me voilà qui il a écrit
un bouquin il parle de son métier sa
trajectoire
on est en direct les commissions de pair
avec lui en lice la concision à faire un
film avec cinq ans c'est magnifique
c'est que l'humanité que de l'amour que
des belles choses
donc je dis semblant alain deloche
le héros vous préférez robin des bois le
héros vous détestez être un charmant
c'est grave
quoi qu'est ce qu'on paye cher tout non
celui là je surveillais le plus grand
acteur du monde pour vous oui et le plus
nul bague il est tellement nul qui
serait que je peux dire sans partition
un pack la plus grande actrice du monde
je crois que c'est moi
et la crise d'avis nul du monde elle
valoir les marier avec la clé un peu
mieux et c'est fun owni ne
risquent-elles que sexy en vo muriel
c'est ici c'est tristan d'euros j'irai
peut-être là c'est dire est que
peut-être c'est mon ambiguïté peut-être
votre bouche comme tout petit peu je
n'ai jamais vraiment ce qu'il ya de
moins sexy en vo merial ça fait sept
mois 5 6 et pense qu'on n'a pas te donne
pas cette ambiguïté je sais pas je m'en
bourg je sais pas c'est moins sexy
c'est pas mal plus direct ce que vous
préférez dans le sexe alors dans le sait
que j'aime beaucoup la partie qui
affamant est-ce qui vous dégoûte dans la
partie qui avec un an d'avancé
le vvd dépendants
cc